congratulations first of all on season
three uh but also congratulations on
season four that was announced and
although that is a huge announcement is
there a sort of bitter sweetness to it
knowing that this will now definitely
come to an end
yeah definitely and and and you know
just from for my part probably not
shared by the other cast members but
there's a sort of stress because i'm
like okay so then are we really gonna
face the truth what what's gonna happen
so
you know it's uh
it's it's you know it's been a stressful
show to try and figure out how these
people operate under such pressure you
know so
um yeah there's relief too though
there's a relationship
uh rupert do you share that same dude do
you find is it a stressful experience
doing the show as a viewer it's very
stressful but i'm wondering what it's
like for you guys on on set what's the
vibe on set when when you're not
actually in a scene do you try and keep
it light
yeah i think you have to the the subject
matter like this is as heavy as this and
it's kind of upsetting i think
it would be impossible not to try and
find those moments of levity and i think
i mean
if you come and visit the set right off
camera we're constantly always laughing
um which is kind of weird because it's
such a dark place to be like i mean
there's particular corners of the house
like uh the nursery i just it does
something to my body just just feel very
uneasy in there it's very hard to relax
so yeah i can definitely
relate to the stress um
and actually yeah it's not really
occurred to me about kind of where
where we will eventually go in season
four i have no idea
it's very hard to predict exactly what
this show is and like
is it
supernatural or
i mean everything kind of being
explained so it's it's it's
very kind of disconcerting and uh and
and toby for you anybody who's ever been
a new dad knows what knows what new dad
mode is like were you ever on those days
where you're like i don't want to be
sean today i just want to be toby and
stay in new dad mode today yeah yeah 100
it's uh it's um you know
it's such an interesting thing i was
talking to rupert about it because you
know uh rupert's a new dad just before i
was and so you're in that position where
you like
i suddenly realized i don't care about
anything but this individual so you're
sort of
all absorbed and then you've got to go
and i i don't want to leave her i really
had a difficulty going to work in the
morning my wife was like just get out
just leave i think they were relieved to
get rid of me but um yeah it's it
yeah it's
it's such an amazing thing to do and
then to go into work and do that but i
think that's the that's the dedication
everyone's shown to this project is that
it is that stress is available
to play which makes it very easy to play
the the the drama of the whole thing and
the tension and the thrilling aspect of
it because everyone's so dedicated and
it's just wonderful to share scenes with
such brilliant actors you know so
and i'm sure that you guys have people
in your lives who are fans of this show
um how much do you say like are do you
have people in your lives that know
everything or are you like great at
keeping secrets
we don't know anything
you don't know we can't tell her my
wife's always like what so what's
happening i'm like i don't know i have
episode seven i don't know what's
happening so yeah we're shrouded
and uh rupert before i uh before i let
you go um you're very used to
these projects that sort of take these
long periods of your of your life um are
you more comfortable with these sort of
long-term plans uh with a project than
you are say like doing a one-and-done
film
yeah absolutely i can definitely yeah i
mean it's to kind of
build a character over a long period of
time is something
what i'm kind of used to i mean this is
we've been doing this like five years
now so it's getting on
it's been kind of another
kind of
massive
journey and it's yeah no i love it it's
great you really get time i think to
to really i mean this is different
because it's it's totally said we don't
really know what what is around the
corner you're kind of always trying to
guess it and
it's never it's never right so it's yeah
it's it's
you always have to kind of think of your
feelings that's been a really
interesting
part of working on a show like this
really appreciate uh your time
congratulations again on everything and
the babies in the show in the season
four and hopefully next time we chat we
can all be in the same room together
thank you